last seen at Christmas back in the
family fold he is the prince without
portfolio and it's a year since the
queen stripped prince Andrew of his
Royal roles a year too since he settled
a sexual assault case brought by
Virginia Geoffrey but could that now be
challenged by his lawyers highly
unlikely say some I think there is about
a 0.0 chance of a court overturning a
settlement leading lawyer Wendy Murphy
says the timing is significant there was
a one-year gag order imposed on Virginia
defray that expires in February of this
year
so part of what we're watching could be
an attempt by Prince Andrew's lawyers to
delay that expiration to put some
pressure on her not to start talking
about what happened
one person who is now talking Elaine
Maxwell the convicted socialite
imprisoned for trafficking and grooming
girls for sex offender Jeffrey Epstein
she's lost all credibility but in an
interview repeats claims made by prince
Andrew this Infamous photo is fake I
don't believe it's real for a second in
fact I'm sure it's not I don't believe
it happened
and
um
certainly the way as described would
have been impossible her comments have
been dismissed by Virginia Joffrey's
lawyers prince Andrew has always denied
the allegations and didn't accept
culpability as part of the settlement
but many say he remains a reputational
risk to the Royals regardless of whether
in fact uh the photo uh with Virginia
Roberts as she then was was faked as
jalaine Maxwell is claiming in the
interview I think that's by the by I see
no reason why Andrew would be seen as an
asset to poor family going forward
prince Andrew has never been convicted
but it's hard to change public opinion
and Elaine Maxwell's comments from
behind bars will do little to help
Laura bundock Sky News